welcome to the world of Steel a massive
open world partially set in the elves at
the intersection of Italy Austria
Switzerland and France we're currently
flying over agreed them alone and in
case you're wondering agreed names
needles
first thing we'll do is land on the
small rock over there notice the man on
the right walking up to the summit
that's another player from the community
from here we can now enjoy the view and
observe the world around us that big guy
in front of you is won't blow the
biggest summit in the region in the
distance you can see the Matterhorn one
of the wildest spots in the game and on
the right you've got the oddity rain the
range we come from where Ubisoft an c
stands in steep we developed a really
cool observation tool we call it
mountain view mountain view allows you
to zoom out from your position observe
the world and navigate into the
environment our mountain range will be
populated by drop zones drop zones or
entry points for you to drop in the
world when you're ready now let's go
back to our initial position besides
drop zones the game will offer a wide
range of challenges for you to test your
skills the one in front of us is a
wingsuit activity and as the other
player drops in will follow him and
trigger the challenge
this is a proximity flying race
challenge
you
we just secured the silver mountain and
as we land we could choose to move on to
skiing in the egg we but we'd like to
introduce you to another region so let's
switch to mountain view and head over to
oughta be
the purpose of this next sequence is to
show you what it's like to play online
with other players such as your friends
or community numbers
did you ride you'll keep meeting other
players who are also having fun in the
mountain let's wish up point of view to
follow those riders as you probably
notice the game will support GoPro be
hold on we really need to positive too
much has happened at the same time now
I'd like to show you something special
if we go back to Mountain View take a
look at that trail every line you do in
the world creates a trail and that trail
is really cool it not only allows you to
check what you've done on your ride so
you can analyze your line but it also
allows you to launch a replay of what
you've seen and what you've done you can
rewind pause control the camera go slow
mo
all any players who've met
and the idea here is to allow you to
push that replay of your performances
hurt or just crashes to all social
networks so you can share it with the
world even better not only can you share
your videos but say you like that jump
over the cliff you know it's a tricky
one you can push it as a challenge to
your friends you define the rules share
it so it becomes part of the content
your friends will see in their games but
let's catch up with our red paraglider
you
you